hey what's up guys my name is Jonah and
welcome to episode 15 of the
serialization series so today we're
going to attempt to finish this series
so to speak so last time we of course
implemented the deserialized function
for the object right if I go to RC
object we implemented this deserialize
method everything was pretty much
completely there except for the actual
other DC realisations that we have to do
which were fields strings arrays now
they're all pretty simple to deserialize
really so I'm gonna go ahead and try and
finish that up today so that we can
basically be done in the next episode if
I do have a next episode which I
probably will I'm just gonna kind of use
that as a closer and maybe give you guys
some other things that you could do to
optimize the current library that we
have here although I think we're gonna
pretty much wrap this up so let's take a
look at what we have to do to
deserialize we've got fields we've got
strings and we've got a raise let's
begin with fields because they're the
first thing we have the best way to look
at how you do utilize something is
actually looking at the way that you
serialize it right when you're designing
a format the first step as we did as
well is actually writing the format when
you're reading the format all you really
have to look at is the way that you
wrote it and pretty much just reverse
this instead of writing bytes we should
be reading bytes so if we come over here
I'm going to go down to the very bottom
I'm gonna type in public static RC field
deserialize we're gonna have our byte
stream called data and a pointer we're
going to again read in the first byte
which is I'm just gonna copy this right
now okay cool so first thing we're gonna
do is read in the container type so
we'll do int or bias container type
container type equals data at pointer
plus plus right I'm gonna set to make
sure that our container type is in fact
the containers I've alright okay cool
the next step is the name length from
the name so this is again gonna be
identical to the way that we did it here
so I'm going to pretty much copy that
I'm going to make our RC field which is
our result
whoops and just set it equal to a new RC
field we've got a private constructor
perfect
we'll set resolve the name length and
result of name here to exactly what we
need the next step is the type okay this
is where it gets interesting because
there are two things we have to consider
here first of all getting the type is
going to be easy right the type is just
a single byte so all we really need to
do is say byte type I guess or result of
type in fact just equals data at pointer
plus plus right we got the type and now
we need to think about the actual data
because we could of course just say
result dot data or whatever it was I
think pointer equals read bytes or
something read byte that just raised a
single byte right however how do we read
a byte array though do we not have that
we might not have that I guess not I
guess we don't
okay sure so read bytes will do read
bytes
we've got sauce pointer length and then
all this will do is basically all rather
source pointer length let's do something
like this instead let's do so source
point and then the destination okay and
then we'll use that destination length
to get where we want to go so we'll set
I equal two pointer we'll say I is less
than pointer Plus destination dot length
I plus plus and then we'll just go ahead
and copy that at first byte so we'll say
destination destination is probably
going to be let's let's rewrite this
little
we'll say zero and we'll say length I
plus plus and we'll say destination I is
going to equal sauce pointer plus I okay
in the metal just nicely copy that data
and give us a I'm not sure if we really
I think when we read things we generally
tend to return them anyway so I guess in
this case we can return pointer if we
really wanted to I think we'll just
return void though okay cool so that we
have it we can read an arbitrary source
of bytes here based on the length that
we provide so we know that the type
tells us what the size is because we can
query that by going to type dot get size
so we can just check the size so we can
say byte or result of data rather equals
new bytes type get size results dot type
and then we can just say read by it from
data at pointer with results data as
we're reading into okay I'll read bytes
rather and then that's it we can return
our result which is pretty cool so that
of course returns void okay cool and
then if we really wanted to of course we
can say pointer plus equals let's see
pointer plus equals this right now the
other problem that we have here is we
don't really know what the size is
I mean the like for us to read the size
we need to make sure that we have data
that length in and I guess we do know
the size actually why don't want to come
to think about this because there's no
kind of update that we have to run the
same way that we did in field or object
in fact this is field but the way that
we had to update the object size or
anything it just knows because of course
the only to dynamic things that has are
the length of the data on the length of
the name both of which we set here so
everything should be good as far as that
goes cool so do we have a way to get the
name of the field no we don't so let's
go back into our c object
we'll still get name alright here we go
and in fact I guess we'll move that up a
bit
okay cool so we can get the name now and
then I guess we can get the size as well
if we really want to so everything kind
of checks out there cool let's go on to
a race and I'm just gonna go to RC field
of I'm gonna just copy that I'm gonna
bring that with me into RC array so we
can make an RC array deserialize okay so
how is it's gonna be different
well the container type is still going
to be the same the name length is gonna
be next again this is kind of important
so I think I'm going to go ahead and
steal everything we have in get bytes
just for reference and we can kind of
I'll just put it at the end here this is
now going to be an RC array
okay good we've got a private
constructor so we got the name then we
got the size type count so we can kind
of start referring that to to our little
cheap little cheat sheet that we have
here so names good the next is the size
okay and then the type so we can keep
our type d serialization which is what
this is or rather should I say this
right but before we before that we
actually do need to read an end so we'll
say a result dot size equals read int
and then this will be by its source
which is data and a pointer and we'll do
pointer plus equals four then we'll
reading the type so we've got the Sally
got the tithe now the count which is a
an int as well so we'll just steal that
we'll read in the counts cool and then
finally we actually have to read in
either data whatever we've got a bunch
of different things that we have to read
in depending on what they are now this
is where this gets a bit tricky because
what we've got is a stream of bytes
however what we really want to do is
read it in as a stream of either like
short data char data in da long data
float whatever right so we need some way
to convert our bytes into an actual
array that we want to read okay and
we're just going to use the existing
functions we have in our suit our
civilization writer class to accomplish
that so first of all let's take a look
at this we've got our type switching
here we've read everything we need the
last thing that we read here is you can
say oh this is actually part of the old
card but some I'm just kind of delete
this for now whoops
okay so we've read an account and that's
the last one now all we need to do is
radiant data now we know how long the
data is because of the count okay so
that's also important so first thing
we'll do is we'll sit we'll switch based
on the type so we'll do result dot type
okay and then instead of writing bytes
we're going to be reading them obviously
so in this case we're going to do read
bytes now we already have done that as
in data pointer and then the result of
where we want to store it is important
so for example if it is a byte
we can just say result dot data equals
new bytes
now how do we know how many results of
count of course is the amount that we
have here and yes okay so and then we
can just say that we're reading from
data into result of data and of course
that's the amount of bytes that we
expect to read now the next step is
going to be kind of similar okay it's
just that instead of creating a data
we're gonna be creating a shorts data
right which is gonna be an array of
shorts
all count as well and then we're going
to be feeding that in here now we'll
have to make a function for this so
we'll save as a public static void read
shorts okay so this will be a short
array this short destination here is
what we're going to use now this is
where this gets a bit tricky what we
want to do is we actually want to use
our existing read short to read in the
to read in each element so all we really
need to do is say destination I equals
read short from source I plus pointer
okay
or rather we don't even have to use I
plus point occurs we actually pass in
source and then pointer all right and
then the other thing is important is
that that returns a short okay so we
know that our pointer has to be plus
equals to every every single element
because of course a short is to two
bytes so we'll just say get sighs what
does it type what even what even are the
types that we made our bite is type okay
so it wasn't it type dot yeah type
they'll show that's what I want okay
cool
so that way we should be able to read it
all the shots now we'll have to
duplicate this of course for everything
so read shorts read int what else we
have chars so I think I'll just move
this down here chars Long's floats
doubles and bullying's so Long's floats
doubles and billions Long's floats
doubles and blends cool so Reid ends of
course is going to do read int and then
taking an int array and then this will
be type int or integer then we'll have
Long's so I skip chars I did skip chars
so cha-cha read char
okay that looks pretty good long read
long alright looking pretty good then we
have floats and doubles so this will be
floats this will be read floats this
will be read double double and bullying
okay there we go so that should be
pretty good we should be able to read
all of the bytes that we have there and
I think show charge I'm just checking
everything I think that is all correct
cool so there we go back in RCRA now we
of course replace read bytes with the
red shorts and we have the short died
and everything works out well so let's
do that for all of these okay so char
data equals new char array and of course
char data is what we take in here and we
are reading Charles okay integer there's
a lot of stuff here unfortunately we
have to replace into data and Donna Reed
and long great Long's
flirt let's double so many data types so
many data types
why have I done double and then finally
bullying okay so that looks pretty good
to me
um I think we're good
so that should read everything and then
of course if we want to advance the
pointer which we didn't really have to
do but we can it will just be point two
plus equals result count times we could
advance the pointer for each of these
but it's fine I'll just do result of
count times type get size result dot
type there we go
and I think that's it right yep that's
definitely it so we should be able to
deserialize arrays now and that should
all be perfect so let's move on to our
final challenge which is a string so how
do we destroy a string well glad you
asked let's go back to field and steal
that definition it's a bit shorter than
it's a bit shorter than the one that we
have in array so return our C string
again we'll just make sure that
container type checks out then we'll
create an RC string good we've got a
private constructor so let's look at
this really we just have the name and
then we have the size count and
characters okay sure so a little dot
name that's all good result dot size is
going to be read int data pointer result
or rather pointer of course equals four
just the one that's straight off name
then we've got count which is another
end
good and then finally we've got the
actual data which is an array of
characters so now that we've made that
situation up we can easily make that
work so we can just say that result dot
data I believe right now it's called
characters but all the characters is a
new char array is going to be a result
of count then we'll read that in so
we'll say read chars start a pointer and
result of characters and if we really
want to advance that pointer it would be
pointer plus equals type dot get size
type char which is two bytes and of
course result on count times that and
then finally we just need to convert
that into a string so that we can get
the string now that this doesn't have a
get string unfortunately so let's let's
make that so first of all we'll have to
get a get name going you'll also note
that by the way we are outputting a
string as a char rather than a byte
okay and we're just allowing basically
chars of course are two bytes so we are
kind of allowing our strings to be like
unicode rather than just one by ASCII so
of course in this case we're we're
allowing two by characters write
something like utf-16 that's our maximum
we don't we're not supporting the utf-32
or anything like that but this should be
enough for pretty much everything cool
so that that's just a little thing that
I felt I should mention because you can
see that names are one byte characters
whereas these are two byte characters so
that's a bit different as well okay so
we'll get getname now I'm hoping I
actually don't know this I'm hoping that
we'll put in get name first of all but
also I'm hoping that gets string that
there's actually something in string
that takes in
the character thing so if we have let's
say we watch our value I like it's a new
string so that represents the sequence
of characters contain in the game okay
fantastic so we can't actually do that
really easy so we'll just say characters
and we're done and that actually should
be it okay that should work perfectly
I'm hoping so if we go back to our RC
object now that we've got all these
three figured out let's get rid of that
for now we can say something like
results dot field counts that is of
course our fields point of particles to
digitalize fields here so we'll now go
through and iterate through these field
counts okay
and again this is going to be something
that is identical to the way that we did
it here in database where we actually
went through the object count and we
destroys the object and then once the
pointer and then add at that it's gonna
be exactly the same thing right so if we
go back to our C object we're going to
create a new RC field so our field in
this case will be RC field dot e
serialized data pointer right I'm going
to go ahead and say fields or result of
fields dot and field and pointer plus
equals field dot get size copy that do
the same thing for strings so this would
be spring count RC string string do
serialize strings add strings and
pointer equals string to get sighs okay
and then finally the same for arrays so
array count RC array scrub that arrays
and array and there we have it
okay cool so if I made no mistakes here
which is actually unlikely this this
should pretty much work and it should
give us our hacia objects so again I
have no idea
what's gonna happen I mean it should
work though because we know that we we
have iterated through the entire file in
terms of objects so unless we made a
mistake with the size somewhere which
again is just very possible everything
should be okay so that being said let's
I guess we can test this out now so
let's see what happens so first of all
let's say that this still works right
and looks like we crashed with a string
index out of bounds again it's a string
index out of balance so this has got to
be so an RC field the civilization did
not work so let's go back to here and
see that this is the first field mmm
interesting because the fields should be
straight off okay cool so that bed is
interesting
the first field failed really so pointer
is 200 L like a show-cause but
digitalizing that massive array wait
I've just got a little thing I want to
check yeah that's fine that's wrong
though because why is the point fields
are stored before fields are stored
before a raised way hang on a minute
that's the reason this is if we want to
early out that's why we should not be
advancing the pointer by that much there
we go so we still work yeah that was I
was gonna say the reason I worked that
out is again so quickly was because that
pointer was at like 200 thousand which
is because we've got this massive array
here but remember even though we do add
the array first arrays are actually
written out last so there's no way the
point it would have iterated through the
array before fields since fields the
first so that was a as a close call
there okay so we've got we should have
everything now yeah so if we go back to
main I'm not gonna bother printing out
everything that'll take forever I am
just going to kind of put a breakpoint
like right here
I don't know if I can do that doesn't
look like it that's why I was gonna
write something so I put a breakpoint
right here we should just be able to
look through the structure okay
so if I go debug and hopefully this all
checks out let's take a look at what we
expect first of all so we expect looks
like an array of random numbers we
expect an integer to be set to 8 x
position Y position to shorts 2 and 43
another object called entity which just
has a string that says hello world which
will really only be able to see if we do
get string and then we've got this asks
our C string create as well so we've got
a string that is another example string
oh we've got a character array versus an
actual string that we have and then
we've just got two objects one of them
has a boolean set to false whatever so
let's take a look at this database of
ours has a size of two hundred thousand
three hundred and six okay I expect that
to be correct we've got a name whatever
weird the name checks out so let's take
a look at objects first of all how many
objects do we have five objects so
that's I'm guessing correct let's see so
database 1 2 3 4 5 ok 5 objects make
sense each of these objects the first
object should be this big one so it
should be called entity again I don't
know if it if it is called energy it's
called three fields three fields good
it's got two arrays also good one string
I'm hoping for yeah one string the name
is that the fields that it has ten
fields really ten fields no it doesn't
have ten fields it's got three fields
why is that I guess that might be the
size of the actual list it's fine I
didn't know that y'all showed you that
we've got the data eight there's our
integer anyway you can see that we can
kind of look through this and I'm
assuming that this data is correct it's
hard to tell I mean that age looked like
it was right what else we have X
position so we should also see two and
forty-three so for the data to good as a
show it clearly then the other one
should be 43 which is going to look a
bit
different okay now it's actually
politically 43 I forgot this display
wasn't in hacks so there we go
now looks pretty good to me let's look
at something else so witless we should
be with the third object would have this
boolean set to false so if we go to the
third object which is this one not this
one no hang on this is the last object
no it's the second last object so it's
object number four then then tie ok well
the size is 26 sure and it should just
have one boolean so field count is one
one field size is one perfect and it's
got one field and the field is type a
but I'm guessing it's bullying and the
data is just false okay fantastic so
there we have it you can see that we've
actually now we have the ability to
deserialize actually worked from the
first time so I'm actually really happy
we've got the ability now to deserialize
all of this stuff that we have here
let's quickly also loop through our
other things just for peace of mind just
so I can output them so we'll loop
through our fields right and we'll just
print the names right so fields lists
and database dot Fields dot oh sorry
left it so we'll even through our
objects and then these are the objects
okay sure so object stop fields objects
dot yet I thought fields which is
private
why is everything private this is so
annoying there's no point in making this
stuff private by the way because we're
clearly gonna be accessing it
immediately so like certain things
shouldn't be accessed like the strength
pound isn't a reason but this stuff
definitely should be okay because
especially because remember if we do
make a getter for fields we can still
modify fields it's it's even if we make
a getter and I said oh we can still we
can't change this part of the field but
we can't change the contents of
so it's up far as I see it public is
totally fine okay back in Maine so
fields dot size I plus was wow that's a
big statement will say system dot print
line database start no you know what
it's just gonna get really messy if I
keep doing this so I'm just gonna say
I'm convert these into 4-h loops I'll
see object object in reach of those in
database objects then we'll make an
object so I'll see you object oh we
don't need to call us that's the whole
point
so that's easily done
oops
okay now we go through the object field
so I'll see field field in object dot
fields and we'll print out a field dot
get name so we'll indent that even more
and then yeah we'll do the same thing
for string so in this case I think we'll
just print out we could print out the
name yeah we'll do that that's one will
probably make a bit of a break here
okay cool so we got the strings now
string dog cat name and then finally
array this is again just making sure
that everything works do arrays not have
names I guess I just don't have a getter
yep
I'll see field get name this really is
begging me to just refactor it so that
well duplicating as much code as we are
but it is what it is okay there we go
so let's run this and see what happens
Wow
a lot of stuff here okay so it looks
like entity has three fields integer X
position and Y position one string
called example string and two arrays one
of which is Rhino numbers the other one
is string Jonah has no fields nothing
turning one is nothing turned two as a
single bullying a single field called a
which is the bullying and there are
three there's nothing so there we go
okay everything wants to be in order
we've successfully dis utilized our data
and we gave it a loop through it which
is pretty awesome in fact let's just
quickly also see what the string is so
I'll do a string dot guess string just
curiosity and then you can see our
example string is testing our LC string
class so how awesome is that we've got
of sterilization format which is pretty
easy to use next time which is the final
episode so at 16 is going to be our
final episode we're going to actually
explore how we can use this and we'll
probably extend the API a bit and we'll
talk about how we can actually use this
in an actual kind of game scenario
because all this is like in our little
sandbox testing you know if I had an
actual entity class that I wanted to
deserialize and serialize or if I had an
actual game state how can I use this
serialization format for that okay so
when I look at some real-world scenarios
next time and actually see this in
action and I'm sure that along the way
in that next video we'll also be able to
extend the API of our solarization
library because we'll see that maybe
some things could be a lot easier so
anyway thanks for watching if you
enjoyed the video please hit the like
and I'll see you guys next time goodbye